good morning millennials
happy monday welcome back to the morning
toast hope everybody had a
fabulous relaxing rejuvenating renewing
weekend yes happy monday i had a nice
weekend i could have like gone for one
more day of weekend
yeah you always can actually sometimes i
feel rested super
satisfied from the weekend yeah no when
i woke up this morning i was like 90
sure it was sunday but i'm having one of
those days where like it's sunday but i
think it's a monday no but it was
actually monday and it was
really depressing way to wake up that is
quite depressing
but it was a pretty good weekend i
actually watched so much tv i read a lot
and so i'll have a lot to share in our
tv recap segment fabulous in our tv
recap
i haven't turned on my tv in a whole
week
because i just had been reading except
for to watch house eyes for this show
but like
in terms of binging there are so many
shows that i watch that have new seasons
like billions bold type
queen of the south like i have so much
money moisture no i watch money hunting
finally after after years of talking
about it
but so i watched bold type season four b
because there was a break
so i watched the rest of the season i
watched them just take everything that
was great about the show and just drive
it right into the ground
and then i started billions the new
season
so good and i watched our toast movie of
the week which is i think maybe i don't
want to
speak too soon but might be our fake my
favorite dumb we've ever done
we will get into it again i'm never done
we're also going to assign our next
movie of the week but yes i totally
agree this was a fantastic choice
i've i literally have like pages and
pages in my notes wanting to like
mention so many things
i really loved the movie it was a it was
honestly in the same vein as like the
color of friendship
like kids movies directed really for
kids but
ageless timeless lessons it was spot on
i was laughing i was crying i literally
was getting
chills the whole time at one point i got
full body chills from my fingertips to
my toes yeah no it was a fabulous choice
so
thank you to everyone who recommended it
and it continues one person suggested it
like a while back when we
started up to a movie of the week again
i just remembered it in my head so
whoever that was back in june you know
who you are probably who suggested it
thank you thank you so much um hope
everyone had a fabulous weekend jax can
i ask you a question
sure do i look any different to you okay
um
i don't know but but i know that you did
something that i actually want to ask
you about
yeah like the shaving of the thoughts i
shaved my thoughts even though
like to say you shaved your face makes
it seem like you're from the greatest
showman the bearded lady no
um no you know marilyn monroe shaved her
face every day yeah so it's not really
face shaving it's dermaplaning yeah and
it's not really like a razor i'm not
taking my billy razor across my forehead
it's like these tiny thin
like japanese blades that i got from
sephora which by the way i went to
sephora this weekend for like the first
time in months
and i have to give them major kudos it
was such a fabulous experience oh that's
so great to hear because i went a little
while ago and i found it to be a little
stressful but i actually need to re-up
on my makeup so maybe i'll go and have
the same fabulous experience and i do
want to hear about
your derma planing because i think the
experience you had putting on your
makeup today was the exact opposite
of mine i literally had so many crumbles
because i like washed my foundation
brush
and i got a bug bite on my face last
night let me see where
it's here and so oh i see um i put it
was red so i put some like green
primer color correcting color correcting
and all of it just it was crumbles you
know you need to
shave your face i've been dying to do it
i just see videos on instagram which is
i know not a good place
for like asses esthetician like tips
but i i've just been really wanting to
do it i've heard so many benefits
you're not really like shaving your like
mustache areas where you grow
black well not you but like people like
who look like me grow black thick hair
like upper lip and eyebrow
you're supposed to avoid those areas
because that type of hair is prone to
grow back
much thicker and faster but if you're
shaving the peach fuzz like on your
cheeks
near your hairline your forehead your
chin um and i did my nose
it's not supposed to grow back any
different and it can take like six weeks
to grow back so you don't have to shave
your face
that much and what i found to be the
most beneficial
part i watched a million videos on how
to do it and i watched it from
estheticians
not beauty gurus because i feel like i
want the real deal yeah
and one of them said something so
interesting she's like most people skip
their nose
but if you have a lot of blackheads on
your nose you can literally and
like a lot of them are like full term
you know you can literally
scrape and see like the tops she was
calling them the plugs come
out and i have so many blackheads on my
nose and i cover them up with makeup
really well but
when i was done i had about 75 percent
less blackheads on my nose it was so
crazy
and then you're not supposed to really
put on makeup so i took like eight hours
but then i had to go to dinner so i put
on makeup
and i put it on super fast but this
morning i gave myself a lot of time to
do my makeup with my new skin and
it literally is such a visible
difference okay i'm gonna do it because
i'm actually the queen of peach fuzz
but they say you're really supposed to
do it at like a facialist like it's much
better to go to a real esthetician but
that's not an option for me right now
and i need a new skin fast that's not an
option right now even though we entered
phase four
did we today yes i got a notification is
that indoor restaurants
nope it's um zoos and botanical gardens
well zeus should be shut down
i know that like you've really been
struggling in quarantine because you
weren't able to
go to the local botanical garden yeah no
that's 100
and so i think that's something that we
should do this week really cheer you up
yeah i mean i actually almost got
married at the brooklyn botanical garden
um so actually going back there brings
back like these terrible memories
because i didn't end up getting married
there very sad well
i think i might shave my thoughts you
should think about it i think i'm
actually the perfect candidate one peach
fuzz everywhere
it's peach fuzz it's dead skin and two
blackheads i have so many blackheads on
my nose and i'm the opposite of you i do
not go after
the things growing on my skin like it
pops on its own you know i really give
them agency
and free rain what free rain free rain
and so
the blackheads on my nose just you know
they live there they pay rent
and they weren't going to be invicted
anytime soon are they good tenants they
they are you know they're pretty
predictable but you know sometimes
they're late
yeah that's annoying but i'm a nice
landlord you should think about it watch
a bunch of videos
don't like just don't go grab a razor
and then [ __ ] shave your face like
watch the videos you have to cleanse you
got to use a witch hazel
and you have to hold the razor at a very
specific 45 degree angle
but literally seeing all like the dirt
dead skin and like schmutz accumulate on
your face as you scrape the razor down
is one of the most satisfying things
ever
okay cool you've really you've
influenced me i have been
influenced and you know i will use your
swipe up links so that you can get
thank you affiliate you know you're not
easily influenced
no i'm not i'm pretty sad in my routine
you know i
i actually i feel like i'm influenced by
by influencers i feel like
at least in the last few years when i
really buy something new or try
something new
it's because i've been influenced by
influencers me too i was so influenced
by sophia richie's um vogue makeup
tutorial that's really the last thing
that really changed my makeup routine
like
brushing up my eyebrows every day and
now i look at old pictures my eyebrows
were so saggy and now they're like
i bought the bobbi brown luminous
foundation from her
video too it's actually a fabulous
foundation i bought her eyeshadow this
isn't a story today but i think her and
scott are back together which just warms
my heart um are there kardashians and
addison wright story they are not a
story i meant for them to be store
because that's really like the celebrity
news that clogged my weekend but then
when i was looking for stories like no
one was really writing it up but
let's talk about it i think we should
talk about it because it's important for
the culture
addison ray is 19. she's a tick-tocker
if you don't know she's
one of the top two maybe three most
famous tick-tockers in the world
um and she in the past has very few
times hung out with courtney and her
family
and i think the impression as consumers
that we got is that like mason
maybe obsess her work yeah mason's
obsessed with tick-tock and because he's
not 14
he got his tic-tac page taken down so
i think in an attempt to be like a cool
mom kourtney kardashian reached out to
addison she like came to the house
it's like kylie getting the trolls cast
to come over for stormy
is courtney getting addison to come over
to like be with mason and honestly it
never really seemed
so odd to me like i just thought it was
like really cute but this weekend they
did take it to another another level
where i believe that they're all staying
in a house together in malibu that's the
impression i'm getting as well
and um my friend simon is there and i
like literally keep texting him he's not
answering me i'm like i need to know
what's going on with addis and ray
um because they've taken it to another
level and it's it's like she's they're
now really hanging out with courtney
yeah no they're one big happy family
from what i gather
this is the people in attendance addison
courtney courtney's kids
north yes i saw north simon pip
simon's beyonce scott and i saw
i don't know if she's there the whole
weekend but kendall joined them for a
beach walk
inter-assignment yes so i literally saw
like addison so kylie was posting
pictures on that staircase
the other day wow it's it's really
interesting
maybe the whole family's under one roof
i would love to see that with addison
like that's crazy
it feels like she's really fitting in so
well honestly i feel
very like protective almost over these
like young tick talkers who are getting
literally reaching astronomical levels
of fame in record time
and i really feel like a lot of them
were like made for it like i feel like
charlie and addison
are like handling everything that's
coming their way really gracefully
and not letting it get to their head and
they i really feel strongly that they're
good role models for
like young girls and i feel like addison
i don't know i'm just like so impressed
by her ability to like stay in a house
with kourtney kardashian for the weekend
you know
totally and as far as like hanging out
with good celebrity influences goes
hanging out with
the entire kardashian family you know
say what you want about them but they're
a great unit they they don't really do
they don't do trouble
i really like this for her yeah you know
she could be hanging out with anyone
in the celebrity world that she wants
and she chooses a family moment
and we love that so we have no choice
but to stand yeah no i think it's great
like i'm curious to
to know more like logistically i'm
curious to understand like is there a
friendship really between courtney and
addison or is it more of like a
mason thing mason yeah because the age
difference is
right so to invite one of mason's like
crushes almost to say the house would be
weird and inappropriate so i don't think
that that's that
i think maybe her courtney just like got
along well yeah which is crazy
because i feel like if addison were to
hang out with like any of the
kardashians it would be like
chloe kylie no not even age-wise i'm
talking like personality-wise
oh i don't know her personality well
enough i don't know if her personality
type is really like a courtney vibe
it seems like it is but when kourtney
kardashian you calls like you answer
yes and when addison calls you answer so
both girls are picking up the phone
you know it's fabulous i'm really here
for it i'm definitely i have the initial
shock like everyone else does but
people are like ragging on it but i
think it's like all fun and good and
cool no i had the initial shock and now
i'm truly living for it like i'll be sad
when this rental is up and everyone goes
back to their respective homes yeah
because the content is so
good and addison like tick-tocking with
all the kids running in the background
just like it's we couldn't dream this up
it's what 2020 dreams are truly made of
that was
what 2020 was supposed to be yes but we
got sidetracked
we got so sidetracked wow
okay well i'm glad that we have the same
thoughts yeah no it's just fabulousness
all around oozing with fabulosity yeah
but maybe now that the weekend's over
like everyone's packing their bags this
morning i
really hope not i hope not also but like
none of them have real jobs so
good things must come to an end that's
true and you know familiarity breeds
contempt so i don't want them to like
start you know hating each other because
they've been in the same house for so
long
i feel you i feel like we're wishing
them the best we are wishing them the
best okay i guess now it's time speaking
of tick tock i do kind of look like a
tick tocker today i feel like those are
very tick-tock pants
with my jeans um snitch gave them to me
oh did you
i look like snitch you do so shout out
to snitch if you're watching this
we miss you um okay
now without further ado i believe that
it is time for the past five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
patreon.com
the morning toast our subscription
service if you love the morning toast
and you want more
you can pay 7.99 for five extra episodes
a month
those five episodes can be podcast
episodes they can be vlogs behind the
scenes more family stuff
you never know what you're gonna get
when you sign up it's a great way to get
more content
and support the show so the link is
patreon.com
the morning toast 7.99 it gets you five
extra episodes a month and
admission into our top secret facebook
group the toast after dark for members
only
true lovers of pop culture and all
things toast
right so if you love the show and you
want more show head over to
patreon.comtoast
or if you love this show and you just
want to support the show head over to
patreon.com
morning toast um before we dive in i
just meant to say
i went to dinner last night at cipriani
and i had the cake
oh yes i saw hold on let me put down
mine yeah no you know what so i was
trying to explain to everyone at the
dinner because i put on my story
rtk and they were like what does this
mean and i'm like
well me and jackie and our friend
heather like went to amfargallen we were
having like this
torturous time and then like we were
about to leave but then this cake came
and they were laughing but like you
really had to be there um and i hadn't
had that cake in so long
and real toasters will remember that
episode where was it after the amfar
episode where heather co-hosted with us
and we just and like we went to this
amazing gal like so incredible
and like all we could talk about was
this cake especially because i think in
the moment
none of us while we were eating the cake
we're like communicating how obsessed we
were with the cake
but then when we all sat down to recap
the night the only thing we could
discuss was the cake
yeah so i had a piece last night and it
was just as good even though
i did eat alfresco last night and
somebody at the table next to me did see
a roach
so and it's i hate to even say that
because it's not in a front
or a dig at the restaurant because it's
just a new york problem it's not like
the restaurant is
dirtier or less it's just it's just
what life is like here and a reason why
you should never move here so
um yes i did have an interaction with
the roach
i heard them screaming and i'm like
please don't be a rat please don't be a
wrap
wow i thought it'd been a while you know
no i haven't i don't i really don't eat
alfresco dining right
same so i thought like maybe the problem
had solved itself nope they're out and
about
so i just wanted to share my little cake
and clyde and
you know you can literally show up to
gianni and try and buy the whole cake
like they'll sell you the cake yeah
someone sent me the whole cake one
someone sent me one too that's a great
thing for a birthday can you just
remember
give me that for my next birthday yes
sure actually your birthday is coming up
i'll get it for you thanks
thanks claudia oh now would also be a
great time to remind you that my comedy
special is out and available you can buy
it you can rent it you can stream it
um all the links are on my instagram in
a highlight called disgrace queen and i
really appreciate the support
and all the positive feedback it really
means a lot to me love it
okay now let's get into it okay sorry
that's like that's all the promo self
promo for today
perfect oh also get your presents at
jackie.com
first story megan fox cuddles up to
machine gun kelly in new photo okay
that's a great headline
there's so much more to this story you
know of course we have not even cracked
with a search we
haven't even cracked the surface but the
article does megan fox and machine gun
kelly's romance appears to be heating up
the twosome cuddled up in a group photo
shared on friday by randall emmett's
instagram page as the film director
celebrated
production resuming on his thriller
midnight in the switchgrass in puerto
rico
quote after four months apart grateful
to be back in puerto rico filming with
this amazing cast adapting to this new
world all quarantined together
emmitt captioned the shot which also
features his fiancee
lala ken as well as stars lucas haas and
emile hirsch
so it turns out that this movie set is
where machine gun kelly which we knew
oh i didn't i didn't realize it was a
randall emmett film we you did
real we knew that so they had met on the
set but then
filming was halted so they all went back
home but
they obviously fell in love on the set
they fell deeper in loving quarantine
and now i'm hoping that we are going to
get a movie that's like the mr and mrs
smith
of our time oh my god we're so in love
she left her husband for him can i just
say that quarantine happened in between
makes it all like kosher because they
went through all the necessary steps can
i just say a mr and mrs smith
reboot with angelina jolie and machine
gun kelly would be
unbelievable with megan fox you mean
what i say you said angelina jolie
oh sorry megan fox yeah angelina jolie
was in the original
um that would be a [ __ ] sensational
movie i would see that in two seconds i
just mean that level of chemistry where
we're watching two people
fall in love in a movie i know but you
accidentally like
created the most genius idea ever that
too i have so many thoughts here you
know that hashtag megan kelly
um someone commented on our instagram
how like megan kelly's a cute name like
a cute celebrity name
for machine gun kelly and megan fox but
honestly it should be
meh gun kelly oh yeah it's so much
better so
now now their names are megan kelly
megan migun
and the second thing is like i just
randall emmett films to me are an
anomaly like i hear about them all the
time and i've literally never
seen one or like even seen one be in
theaters okay
here are some actually i think his most
popular film because it used to be in
his instagram bio is a lone survivor
you didn't watch it probably but i've
heard of it yes
also he participated in the irishman he
said yeah
and gotti which was the big fat failure
um
but also if you go to his imdb there are
a lot of other movies but i think lone
survivor
is the one that was most successful and
that he participated the most in
interest whereas i think he participated
in the irishman at like a one percent
well he was just happy to be there yeah
yeah like yeah so i'm really i think
this is such a great press for the movie
i'm so excited that lala ken
is wrapped up in all of this i hope that
they're like getting
double date dinners together no i will
100
be seeing this movie like now that i
know about it i'm its number one fan
what's it about
um it's called star cross lovers it's
called
midnight in the switchgrass it honestly
sounds so bad but
i'll be seeing it i'll be seeing it at
midnight when it comes out and i will be
in the switchgrass
i will be seeing midnight in the
switchgrass at midnight in the
switchgrass
with a knife colonel sanders yeah no i
totally agree and if you look at this
photo they just look like
two high schoolers who are so obsessed
with no it's like a prose prom picture
like everyone's tired
um i need all the other people in the
photo to get the [ __ ] out because i
think for law and randall
no no just the four of them and then
everyone else has to go sorry
like you i don't know what your role is
in the movie but in this movie you are
not main characters you are supporting
actors and actresses
yeah and if the movie doesn't focus on
like a love between the characters
that meegan and gun play
mr gun kelly yeah um
i i might be showing up at like midnight
the next night i have listened
to that song um bloody valentine where
she's in the
music video for it's a machine gun kelly
song i have listened to it
so many times it's an absolute banger i
think i'm becoming like machine gun
kelly's
actual number one fan not just his
celebrity but also his music [ __ ]
bangs
yeah it's really good it is really good
the emo kid in me is like you know in
the back of the car like [ __ ] nodding
my head against the window
does ben like machine gun kelly i feel
as though he would i'm not sure if ben
knows about machine gun kelly but i have
to play bloody valentine friend because
that is ben's
chosen genre of music like emo like a
nod to like 90s simple plan
you know it's like if someone if the
singer's being like yeah yeah like
that's ben's genre like yeah
yeah but i feel as though he doesn't
discover new music he just sort of
listens to the old one 100
i feel so i'll start playing it around
the house and then i'll be like hey what
was that song
yeah like my bloody something yeah
totally
yeah so this is just a beautiful update
in the love story
that is these two and i think this is
one of the more positive things that has
come out of quarantine is that it really
gave these two
a fair shot and now they can like go
into their love
on set fairly because uh when the last
time she was on set she was technically
married and
even though like but like you know in
the
public opinion oh and like legally she
was married for sure but that marriage
was
always one minute away from just death
yes and now and machine gun kelly was
here to put it out of its misery
thank you okay next story
jeffree star has put out a video
addressing the tati westbrook
quote situation we have been waiting
girls and the drama about him and shane
dawson in a new
video we have been waiting i completely
forgot that we were waiting
a video dropped so i think that whoever
um like manages or does pr for jeffree
star listens to this show because i gave
him advice he did exactly what you said
he should do
i said if he comes out with a video
receipts and then this this this it
looks like he's exactly the person tati
was describing someone who's
manipulative somebody who holds receipts
someone who blackmails people
so for him to have come out and just be
like i don't blackmail people i'm not i
don't have any receipts here today just
like i'm accepting
kind of responsibility for what i did my
part in all of this
so i think that was a really smart move
and it seems like he doesn't really care
what people think about his apology
video he just needed to get something
out so that he can
can continue on with the rest of his
content his launches apparently
he has lots of stuff yeah videos filmed
like he just wants to move on
with his day-to-day and like i think he
knows that people either hate him or
love him
his video was never going to change
people from loving to hating from hating
to loving
he just needed to for optics and get
something out so that he can move on
and the people who rather die for him
are going to be them for him no matter
what yeah he needs to close the book on
this
and get his opinion on record so that
you know
everyone can reference their favorite
youtuber
um but he didn't want to fan the flames
which he easily could have being like no
this is what happened blah blah blah but
then it becomes bigger and
messier and it's clear that that's not
what he wants so i think that this was
the wise choice especially considering
from what i understand people are not
living for this drama anymore people are
finding it annoying they're finding all
the
characters and players it's annoying and
so
no one is interested in another video
full of tea where they're confused about
how to feel and they're like back and
forth back and forth
agreed so i think he read the room
realized he needed to say something
and what he was going to say was a whole
lot of nothing i i did have a couple
problems with the video
um my the first problem was the couch
i like literally
i'm a fan of jeffree star and i think
that like his makeup brand is super
impressive and i think he has great
taste in makeup and like
his clothes are amazing but his interior
decor style
is just like honestly so trashy and
tacky like that couch was just
a disgrace okay also the acoustics of
the video because
it was so far away yes it it was fine i
could hear what he was saying
but as a professional youtuber it was a
strange choice agreed
the second thing i didn't like which i
think he should have brushed off because
everyone's entitled to their opinion but
to release a video where it's like
you're already being made out to be
the villain and then to just dig your
grave even deeper by like defending
shane dawson where it's like honestly i
respect that he's your friend and you
want to stay loyal to him but like you
just shouldn't
have even addressed it in the video
because what shane is like under the
under fire for is like so important and
disgusting and unforgivable
and i just don't know why you would like
attach yourself to that when no one was
asking like the video was about you
so you think if he made a video
addressing everything that's been going
on
in the last few months and didn't
address shane that people would have
been fine with that
i literally never expected him to
address shane i'm maybe i'm
a singular person but i'm of the mindset
like you are not responsible for what
someone else does or says even if you're
friends
with that person so it's like i never
once expected jeffrey to comment on
shane's cancellation
maybe if he were to talk about shane it
would to be to address what tati said
about them doing together gaslighting
her
but i never once expected nor wanted to
hear his thoughts on shane because i
know that they're friends and of course
everyone's allowed to stand by their
friends
i wouldn't because i would not defend
someone who's a child predator but
everyone's entitled to do that and i
just thought like if he was trying to
make the video as like
alleged i mean it's like child predator
sorry alleged
but naughty no like jokes about child
predator sorry i didn't mean to
speak out uh misspeak but if he was
trying to like let the video just like
slide by like
standard nothing crazy like i just don't
know why he would even bring up the
shane stuff especially if he's not gonna
condemn it
yeah so i guess the only reason would be
that he thinks it's the right thing to
do and that he really stands by his
friend and he wants everyone to know
that
so i just i don't agree with that and
then the other thing i thought was so
strange it's like
i hate when people say like there's so
you know there's so much more important
things going on in the world like that i
have to even address this
so if you really feel that way don't
address it but you just lump together
like randomly like
different causes in the video um and
then saying
all beauty matters and then saying you
know which is true i feel like for as
long as i've been watching his videos
he's always
pushing and putting pressure on brands
to be more inclusive in their shade
ranges
and all that was true i just don't know
how that applies to this like
it was just a real [ __ ] of like
information and content and i didn't
feel like any of it was
fluid or it left me confused and he kept
contradicting himself like i don't know
i just
and i'm a really big jeffree star fan i
just it didn't do anything for me
i honestly couldn't even get through it
and it was only 10 minutes yeah it
didn't do anything for me
in the sense that i forgot that i
watched it but now i guess
we're no longer waiting for a response
from him and he can move on with all of
his other endeavors and
leave all of this in the past which i
think is what he was trying to do i
don't think he's trying to sway any
hearts and minds i think
he's trying to close the book you know
eventually like people have decided and
there's like we
we watch one video where we're tati and
then we're with jeffrey like that's not
really it can only go back and forth so
many times and i think
jeffrey probably reconciled that he lost
a bunch of fans but he still has like
ride or die hardcore fans and they're
gonna be the ones to continue to support
him and he just wants
to go back to normal and this was his
attempt to do that like swiftly
i just did not think the video was well
done really in any way but i put it on
our instagram because i was really
curious
to hear people's thoughts um and here's
the comments i saw was like people
didn't even want to watch it
that's how bored everyone is by this
story so this is from emily ranner she
said i started the video craving a big
juicy hamburger but was served a salad
without dressing
like a hundred percent um someone said
the transition from talking about the
drama within the beauty community
to the atrocities committed against the
black community was very poor
agreed ending it with all beauty matters
was another poor choice
um someone said the couch is hideous
it's gonna be a no for me dog so
i think the overall consensus which by
the way and
this is coming from someone who has been
a really big jeffree star fan in the
past
and i probably still watch will watch
his videos i just this video did nothing
at all like more or less no because a
lot of people are canceling
jeffrey um for things that he did in his
past that have been
rehashed already and he has apologized
for and i'm i'm a firm believer in
growth and change
and no i will i will still watch his
videos and
because like let's even if i do think he
was wrong in the tati stuff which i
think everyone's wrong i think everybody
needs to take responsibility
um that's not something i would ever
stop watching geoffrey for like youtube
dramas youtube drama like that's why we
live for it even when it was happening
i think we all knew that jeffrey was the
bad guy in this story
in this movie but that's like his vibe
like yeah no and
we we all sort of just reconciled that
and moved on to the
you know the docu the shane dawson right
and we just moved on so
this didn't move the needle for me at
all forwards or backwards it's as if i
never saw anything i'm curious if james
charles has forgiven jeffrey
definitely definitely not and if he were
to ever like i think that would really
clear
jeffrey's like name but i don't think
james would ever do that
i think that he would forgive him you
know hypothetically yeah
on the surface but you know it wouldn't
be the same
yeah james charles hasn't spoken on it
and i don't think he ever will
yeah because now he's just enjoying you
know the comeuppance that he deserves
retribution
and you know he doesn't need to
messy himself with this he's getting the
justice that he deserves and sometimes
you have to let justice just roll out in
front of you
and you don't even need to do a thing
yeah justice
truly speaks for itself it does okay
next
story hayden penatiere is breaking her
silence on alleged abuse
by her ex brian hickerson hayden
panettiere has broken her silence on the
abuse she suffered at the hands of her
ex-boyfriend the former nashville star
released a statement on social media
saying she's coming forward with the
hope that she can help others
who find themselves in similar
situations quote i'm coming forward with
the truth about what happened to me with
the hope that my story will empower
others in abusive relationships
to get the help they need and deserve i
am prepared to do my part to make sure
this man never hurts anyone again
i'm grateful for my support system which
helped me find the courage
to regain my voice and my life in the
caption she added you're not alone along
with phone numbers to domestic abuse
hotlines
oh i love her so much you are not alone
and there's something really powerful
about not only coming forward with
your abuse but having everyone know who
you're talking about because she's right
like this is a dangerous person and if
it's not hayden panettiere it's gonna be
someone else you don't just
change from you know woman to woman so i
like love that she did this i love that
she's
looking out obviously she probably
shared this you know for her own
mental health but really for like the
safety of other women who might come in
contact with this man
and like if they ever just were to
google him like they would know in two
seconds that
that's who it is and i just love that
and i really respect her and i feel like
she's had a really tumultuous
um personal life for like the last
couple years between like bad
relationships
and i know she struggled with post
partum depression like and i just i love
her i feel very deeply connected to her
i mean she was in
remember the titans which we're going to
recap really soon um but she's also in
most of like my favorite
childhood movies raising helen like
she's just such an integral part of my
childhood
bring it on yes bring it on two and
three
like slip through yeah yeah three with
also solange knows an iconic film and
iconic
we need to add that to our toast movie
of the week um but i just i love her and
i fee and she like
really fell off the face of the earth
for a while but it's because she's been
dealing with so much in her personal
life
and i just i'm her champion like i love
her and i just want her to be happy and
healthy and like in a good relationship
i agree and i think this is a great step
towards doing that
um i absolutely love her ride with her
and i'm i hope she's doing well and it's
really wonderful of her to put these
resources out for other women
um who might be going through something
similar agreed and hopefully this is
like the end of a chapter for her
and we can start fresh definitely maybe
with the new season of nashville who
knows
oh you guys did you finish nashville no
after it was um canceled on abc like i
didn't stand that hard to like go over
to the cmt channel
no you missed out because then it became
even more country and like less like
mainstream country and it's so good if
you've never watched nashville like
that's a wonderful
show to binge right now it's a good
quarantine show yeah it's so good then
it gets bad of course but then it gets
good again and i loved the way that it
ended
there were just some characters in the
show that like i literally could not
[ __ ] with
scarlett and then her boyfriend at the
time in the beginning
that guy the tall skinny one yes um no
lyle no the one not her first boyfriend
uh with avery not avery no the other one
who's british in real life yes oh my god
the two of them were so [ __ ] annoying
they almost were in the show scarlett
like honestly she was the worst
character like you should talk
like yes i need to find out that guy's
name now because it's
really but it is a good show and it
ended up with great music
gunner scott gunner and it launched the
career
of lennon stella which was just fabulous
and we love a connie britain moment
hayden panettiere truly star-studded
deacon was uh the dad from obx and also
the dad from the last song
and also the dad from jessie no not the
last song jesse
yes um no it really star-studded
really star-studded if you love country
music or you just love shows with music
it's a good show yeah it's a great show
okay next story prince andrew was a
no-show at his daughter beatrice's
wedding
well some good news the princess
beatrice was married on friday
she was a corona bride and obviously you
know she planned to have a big
royal affair uh instead she opted for
something smaller
where just her grandparents queen
elizabeth ii and prince philip
were on hand for the socially distant
ceremony in berkshire
the daily mail reported that b's father
was nowhere in sight as accusations
accusations continue to swirl over his
repeated past visits
to his pedophile pal jeffrey epstein's
now infamous
little st james island in the caribbean
i mean the tea here is running piping
hot uh
well first of all let's start with the
wedding she looked super cute you know
these girls are so nice
um i mean i don't know them but they
look like nice girls and i always think
of um
don't even don't i know what you're
going to say what a girl wants
but yeah like the evil stepsister yeah
that's what they made them out to be and
like for my whole life like that's why i
just associated these girls as but now
watching the crown like understanding
their place in the royal family
they're they're lovely girls and um now
they're both married and they're so cute
and i'm like happy for them and she wore
the crown headpiece that queen elizabeth
wore at her wedding so the queen gave
her something really special she had
something special even though she
had like a non-wedding and her dad
wasn't even there now let's talk about
the dad so
now that i watch the crown i fully
understand that prince andrew is queen
elizabeth's
son you did not realize that before did
you think he was like some some reason
i thought it was related you know okay
big big royal family but he's really
he's in it like the queen is his mom
charles is
brother charles his brother and these
are his kids uncle
these are he's these are his kids yes
and
he's just such a disgrace like he's so
inextricably linked with this whole
gelatine maxwell jeffrey epstein
circle of all the people but powerful
world leaders rich people
his name gets brought up the most he was
so involved and i feel like some other
powerful rich people
are able to you know assuage concerns
being like oh i didn't know this
there's nothing that prince andrew could
say
that would make anyone believe that he
didn't know well
i was watching the information discovery
channel
jeffrey epstein thing and they said like
you know when jeffrey epstein
and all the stuff was coming out there
were a lot of whispers about prince
andrew but it was really like not
confirmed at all
and the palace i think felt that you
know they
that prince andrew could get out of it
in some ways and he did that sit-down
interview with bbc
and he did so much worse and he made it
so much
worse it's honestly a hilarious
interview like i really recommend
um if you're just like not busy ever
watching it because it's hilarious
this is someone who thinks like his [ __ ]
doesn't stink he's untouchable
and then literally he sits down for an
interview and the woman interviewing him
is an
amazing journalist she does not let him
get by on any of the
accounts yeah also virginia grief free
um said that epstein had trafficked her
when she was 17 years old she's one of
the key witnesses
there's a picture of them uh he forced
her to have sex with his friends
including prince andrew she accused the
british royal of sleeping with her three
times
um during the time there's a picture of
them together in a town house in london
yes but there's a lot of pictures of a
lot of people and as you said
some of these you know well yes
celebrities have found themselves in
photos
with galen i said because her job was
being a professional social life but
these young girls being trafficked oh
yeah
they weren't just going to parties with
prince andrew they were there for a
reason
yeah galen just used to show up places
because her job
was to collect social currency friends
rich friends planes
so if you're in a picture with virginia
what was her um
roberts virginia roberts which is
married now so but everyone remembers
the name virginia roberts
um if you're in a picture with virginia
roberts like you are [ __ ] shady
yeah and that virginia roberts is strong
like i remember in the netflix
documentary she said how like when she
first
came out against prince andrew and then
also she said alan dershowitz
she got so much backlash like literally
people they were just doing
everything they could to discredit her
um and her credibility
but it's like not even over like now
like she's
her name is always the one um in the
press and i just i pray that she is like
good people around her because it's so
hard to go through this and this is
literally like
20 years yeah of this it's so hard to go
through it and our fifth and final story
um relates back to our fourth story
because a gunman disguised as little
delivery driver
kills a son and shoots the husband of a
new jersey federal judge
the 20-year-old son of a prominent new
jersey federal judge was shot dead and
her husband was critically injured in an
attack at their home on sunday evening
according to reports
an unknown assailant disguised as a
federal express fedex delivery driver oh
is that what it stands for
i guess so gunned down judge esther
salas's
twenty-year-old son daniel anderl and
shot her 63 year old husband mark
anderle
at the north brunswick home at around 5
p.m authorities told the new jersey
globe
now this is a horrible story horrible
reason why it relates
to what we were just discussing is
because
recently this judge has been presiding
over an ongoing lawsuit from deutsche
bank investors
who claim the company failed to monitor
high-risk customers
including the late pedophile jeffrey
epstein so
four days ago she got this case four
days ago she got a case related to
jeffrey epstein
yesterday her son is murdered at their
home and her husband has been critically
injured
absolutely awful there's no doubt in my
mind that these two things
are linked because this is a very
elaborate hit
you know it's not like some man showing
up at your house with a gun like there's
a fedex truck in a fedex uniform like
this is an elaborate
well put together hit and it really only
makes you think that like powerful rich
people are behind it
yeah especially given the fact that not
four days ago she was given the deutsche
bank
um case with jeffrey epstein apparently
they lied to investors about
even after he like was out and known as
a predator deutsche bank was lying to
their investors about working with
jeffrey epstein and they still were
yeah so the shadiness of deutsche bank
is like a whole other
topic here um but first of all like
this is just such a sad story like i'm
sorry that this this woman is like just
doing her job and
trying to serve the american people and
her son and her husband are
collateral damage in that like that's
that's horrible
and it's really really upsetting and i'm
really sorry to her and her family that
like this is
this is the cost of just like being a
judge like are you [ __ ] kidding me
what the [ __ ]
no and i think we've said so many times
obviously now people are you know
worried that galen
something mysteriously is going to
happen to her um
and even with all eyes on this situation
the people who are committing these
atrocities are
still shameless doing it yeah we're all
talking about it like lady maxwell's
gonna ha ha
she's gonna go missing and it's like
it's not even funny like it's
she's next she should be like shaking
because now first the judge
there are people there not to sound like
a crazy conspiracy theorist
but there are people who don't want this
out galene is going to sing like a bird
so she doesn't
get the maximum sentence she might even
get like a light tap on the wrist
for literally selling out every single
person and you know her and jeffrey kept
diaries they kept sex tapes they had
taped everything on the plane all their
houses
they were all bugged like they have i
don't know where it is
but they have information they have
proof they have blackmail
and she is going to give every last
piece of paper
to save her own ass and there are some
very powerful people who it could
implicate and they are not interested in
being dragged into this
yeah and now i would bet my life they
are behind this atrocity against a
lovely judge in new jersey
who was just trying to do our job this
story is so upsetting
very pit worthy i just
it's a disgrace to the justice system it
is and it displays more so than ever
not that we needed even another reason
why justice needs to be served in the
case against jeffrey epstein angeline
but
this needs to end and i just want to say
anyone
who the [ __ ] would want to be on this
jury you know what i mean like
anyone who is involved in any case
relating to jeffrey epstein
if his name is in one of the depositions
or galen's case
the jury the bailiff the judge the
lawyers everyone
needs police protection like i know i
sound crazy but it's true
this is horrible and the golan's case
hasn't even started
yeah and look an innocent life was taken
of a young 20 year old man it's [ __ ]
terrible it makes me very angry
shame on them
now on a lighter note we're going to
switch over to our toast movie of the
week recap which was remember the titans
but before i dive into that
allow me a moment to tell you about
today's sponsor stamps.com
for all of our sakes we need to avoid
crowds any way we can right now
but what if you need to go to the post
office what if you need postage to send
out letters and packages
don't worry stamps.com is here to help
with stamps.com you can print postage on
demand and skip the lines and crowds at
the post office
plus you can actually save money with
discounts that you can't even get at the
post office
and if that wasn't enough sams.com also
offers ups services with discounts up to
62 percent off and no ups residential
surcharges
stamps.com brings all the services of
the us postal service right to your
computer in the safety and comfort of
your own
home office or anywhere else you're
hunkering down right now
whether you're a small business sending
invoices an online seller shipping out
products
or you're just working from home and
need to mail stuff stamps.com can handle
it all with ease
simply use your computer to print
official us postage 24 7
for any letter any package any class of
mail
anywhere you want to send once your mail
is ready just leave it for your mail
carrier schedule a free package pickup
or drop it in a mailbox
no human contact is required and like we
said with stamps.com you get great
discounts too
five cents off of every first class
stamp and up to 62 percent off shipping
rates
it is a no-brainer saving you time and
money and keeping you safe in these
crazy times
right now our listeners can get a
special offer it includes a four-week
trial plus free postage
and a digital scale without any
long-term commitment so if you want to
get that special offer which is a
four-week trial plus free postage and a
digital scale
go to stamps.com click on the microphone
at the top of the home page and type in
toast
again that's stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the home page
and type
in toast stay safe my friends
love it lovestamps.com okay i have so
many [ __ ] notes
um about remember the titans yes because
i loved it and i didn't even realize but
obviously
it's on disney plus which just made it
really premium viewing experience i
completely agree
my first thought was how star-studded
the movie was i mean obviously like
denzel but i think denzel was a star
even when this movie was made
but ryan gosling um young ryan gosling
uh kate bosworth
your favorite oh yes yes yes and hayden
pantier of course oh hey
okay so i loved the movie
and i loved the message i loved
everything i loved the cast i laughed i
cried but i had one major problem
and that was hayden panettiere's
character like not to just be so
annoying but like
my god she was annoying like we get it
you like football like
she was just so like i felt like her
character i saw
it was obviously someone who was like
young and raised a certain way and it
was
supposed to i think show how that can
change but my god she was [ __ ]
annoying like i just
liked her oh i really did that she was
such a good actress even at such a young
age and also i think what she
represented was just like
this pure love of football you know
because even when
that ref was making unfair calls right
and her dad
coach yost um saw the way his daughter
was reacting like it has nothing to do
with race like this is about football
and doing what's right and what's fair
and she represented just like the game
yeah i guess every character really
served a purpose i agree
i mean for me what i took away from the
movie was like you know
a lot of the older people in the town
who really were the problem they grew up
in a totally segregated city and they
couldn't see past like their own [ __ ]
racial like mindset
whereas like kids are so like when they
all went to camp and got out of like the
[ __ ]
politics of the town like it was easier
for them to just like
get along like they're just boys like
they like football yeah common interest
so it really highlights like the whole
and what we've been saying is like
racism is really learned and it can be
unlearned
and as a kid who's just like you know
living
and who isn't fully developed yet like
it's much easier whereas like these
older people who are so set in their
ways
it wasn't until denzel washington was
like this amazing coach and everyone
loved him he won all the games
that people finally started to respect
him when they should have just respected
him the second he became
we moved to the city yeah you know yeah
um okay wait i have more now hold on
okay um i can't believe ryan gosling
like became so famous and like this was
one of his movies because honestly
um he had the tiniest role and he wasn't
he didn't even look cute like no he was
like
not didn't look like he should be on a
football team agreed um
but he i liked his character he was cute
well so many of the characters on the
football team were
so funny like that i was really laughing
a lot at the movie i
didn't expect so much i loved that
julius and
gary and gary was the one who spoiler
alert ended up passing away
um i loved that like they were the most
they were both like obviously the
leaders of their individual
groups of friends but they were so in
the beginning like not willing to change
they were like the most rigid
and then like immediately like someone
clicked at camp and they just became
like best friends
and then when he was in the hospital she
was like are you blind that's my brother
like i was
living and then like the way julius and
his mom was like really
um gary's mom was like really
close-minded like at the bus when he
dropped them all off
and when julius came over and like gave
the mom a hug and picked her up like i
was
literally sobbing no sobbing their
friendship between them was
was so wonderful to watch like the way
it all played out i agree with
what you said about like what happened
at camp like when they were able to just
detach from their community and what
people expected of them and just like be
high schoolers playing football like
yeah it ha
it's it's not about race and they're a
better team because of it
right and i can't believe this is like
the color of friendship again a true
story like
oh my god i love that it was a true
story i love that they told me in the
beginning that was a true story because
um i would have found out after and been
like oh my god i can't believe that's a
true story
yeah and i just i love truly
every single minute of it so i was
talking about on my instagram and i'm
like i can't believe i've never seen
this movie and ben couldn't believe i
had never seen it either and i was
talking his ex shapiro last night
because it's like as boys like they
loved this movie and maybe it was
because we grew up in a house of all
girls
i feel like we i feel like we had to
have seen this movie but
too like but i don't remember right well
i was saying on my instagram i'm like
this should really be like required
viewing in middle schools because
honestly i felt like it was
such an accessible movie and it spoke
about like serious sad stuff in a very
digestible way yeah um and i thought it
was perfect for kids
and literally everyone responded to me
and they're like it is required viewing
like
literally everyone in the country has
seen this movie they're like literally
they made us watch it once a year in gym
class like
everyone dm'd me so maybe it was just
our school but i feel as though
my schooling failed me yeah oh my god
that is really funny yeah no
literally everyone was like i've seen
this movie like a hundred times they
make sure they make you watch at the
beginning of the year
that is real you know but i'm glad i
hope that they're still doing it because
it's such an applicable movie
and ben was so whenever i cried during
movies ben makes me feel so
uncomfortable like he's literally like
comes up in my face are you crying it's
like tears falling
cry no it's so annoying and and ben
doesn't really cry at movies he was
sobbing and i it took every mature bone
in my body like not to go up in his face
are you okay but i didn't he was so
emotional and
i was confused because they start the
movie with a funeral
yes and then gary gets into the accident
and you're like oh
he's obviously the one who dies oh i
didn't think that because the ages of
the
of mostly hayden panettiere she's i
don't remember i just saw like a blonde
girl
so i just i can't believe that gary was
the one who ended up dying in another
car crash like what
misfortune yeah and it's a true story i
obviously like googled all the people
afterwards i was just so
um like interested in seeing what they
looked like and they did a great job of
casting people who really looked a lot
like their original characters and i
just i loved the movie like i was really
wanting to be like a part of the team
the guy lewis who
said he was too dumb to get into college
and then by the end he had a c plus
average and he's hugging denzel
washington now he's like a prominent
businessman
and that's what i said to ben i'm like
people think it's just like high school
football like it's so silly but it's
like it really sets the tone for your
rest of your life
and really like making especially a lot
of these kids who like might not have
had going on they
a lot going on they weren't good at
school i mean good in school
it gives them like a sense of purpose
and at a young age
that's like really valuable and i said
i'm like look at them they all went on
to have like amazing careers
in the schooling system in sports like
in other stuff
and that wouldn't have been possible
like no one really made them feel like a
winner and feel like they were important
when they were in high school
yeah no i agree like those school
activities whether it be football or
other
being a part of a team learning these
skills doing you know going three-day
practices when that's not what you
choose to do with your summer
uh definitely it makes a man out of you
it it does
and that guy louis like he was just like
i'm not going to college and then he
ended up having this like flourishing
career
yeah oh man i love i always say this
because it's a theme with all the movies
it's like
if any of the movies that i watch ends
with a black screen and white text like
you know it's a good movie and this one
it had the white text and you know even
if the movie wasn't good up until that
point like
now i love it but i loved every single
minute of the movie it's impossible not
to get chills when that text flashes on
the screen
no it's impossible and i love like i'm
so glad they showed us
what everyone else was up to it was kind
of surprising that no one really went on
to play professional football i thought
that too considering they were the
second best team in the country
yeah in the country so aren't those
players like the second best players in
the country like don't they go to the
nfl but i thought that too
i guess it doesn't work that way no but
i um upon researching i saw a picture of
denzel washington and the character in
real life meeting and it was
so i like got really emotional and the
um
the coach actually uh coach boone
died literally december 2019 he just
passed away
but what a legacy what a legacy what a
life
wow fabulous movie thank you to whoever
suggested it because
that is i even feel like i learned some
stuff about football too
oh no i don't like just the way that
that plays go
well yes actually what i did learn is
like football is obviously like who the
best athlete but
it's very strategic like the plays and
when when they got the math coach to
like put
the math teacher to like put all these
numbers together for
uh hayden panettiere's dad um there were
so many characters by the way i
literally don't know anyone's name like
i know like julius gary and like the
coaches but like they were the team
mates i don't know anything i know
oh i knew some of them rev and then
there was ray who got the boot
yes uh yeah it was just hard i was like
literally i know
like their their numbers but i couldn't
remember their name
um but hayden panettiere's dad when he
got that um
playbook or whatever with the math
teacher's notes like
football is really also like strategy
and numbers
yes which i didn't know like the plays
you can be a good team but if you don't
have good plays then you're not
gonna make it yeah it's it's about the
whole thing it's about the whole thing
okay so that was our movie and then for
our next week movie which we'll be
recapping on monday we're doing black
panther
which ben is going to be so excited
about because i don't really watch like
superhero i don't watch marvel
i actually never even saw wonder woman
um and ben has been
ben says that this was his favorite
movie he ever saw actually he also said
about i
remember the titans like maybe he's just
lying um he's gonna be thrilled to know
that i'll watch it with him yeah
so it's black panther like one of the
highest grossing movies of all time yeah
i heard it's phenomenal
and i don't think the highest grossing
movie of all time would be bad
right i'm so excited except avatar was a
little um controversial
i never saw it and it was the highest
grossing movie of all time and i didn't
really like it
well i don't think i would like it
either which is right
i haven't seen it okay well that's all
she wrote
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast millennial morning
show where we post videos on youtube
monday through friday and we're also
available as a podcast anywhere podcasts
can be found that spotify itunes
stitcher public radio ir radio cast box
all the places wherever you listen to
podcasts find us the morning toast and
leave a five star review about how
beautiful stunning and smart we are
we love you guys very much we hope you
have a great day and we'll see you
tomorrow bye
[Music]
goodbye
you